[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu penses de transport en
commun je trouve ça c'est compliqué
premièrement sur les oreilles ça finit
assez tôt on a un petit peu de mal à se
déplacer et j'habite à en banlieue avant
chez ma tante marne la vallée c'était
vraiment assez compliqué et en fait elle
en pense quoi
mon frère bah c'est pas les coûts très
bas les couilles quoi ma mère chine
pousse yade c'est ça que j'entends
chez vous
me sens plus à l'aise je trouve qu'il ya
plus deux ouvertures au cas où il ya un
premier opus comme ça pas dans toutes
les stations mais ça va c'est le métro
quoi et vote s'annonce quoi maquis sûr
j'ai eu une petite soeur à tao la
question est ce que vous pensez
transports parisiens les transports
parisiens franchement emoji aubergines
et emoji smiley qui chialent on n'y est
pas du tout sur les transports en commun
t'en penses quoi
non ça va ça va bombe alors s my gym
conneries en général ça se passe pas
trop mal
oui moi le moi j'allais y est le métro
c'est très bien non franchement parce
qu'on n'est pas bons je vois pas toutes
les musiques du sud
je ne connais pas du tout mais
j'aimerais y a pas de problème il n'y a
aucun souci
ceci à tizi zhao il avait voulu c'est
pas votre frère pas du tout je reconnais
pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]